hi that's eight I'm going with Matt yeah
say yay
I said yeah hey we're going to Paris
it's gonna be a lot of fun we're gonna
shoot the thing that I talked about me
and we're gonna travel to Paris and I'm
gonna walk all by myself
through the catacombs of Paris so it
will be like a real-life horror game
where in London it kind of sucks
I forgot my phone in the car we missed
our train everything has gone really bad
so far is great but where I have to go
that it's good to Perry's account you
know it'll be ready in two figures on
please let me know run transparency
coach it's gonna be too many safety oh
my gosh will be due in Paris for somehow
the weather is worse here than UK I
don't know how that's possible but
that's the thing and I'm wearing shorts
so life is hard man life is hard we're
gonna go to our talent it's gonna be
amazing
Oh Rimmel towel the Wi-Fi sucks but it's
okay we're gonna go and see the movie
now we haven't seen it yet
Gina yeah I'm excited to see the movie
finally and tomorrow is the catacombs
challenge they were explaining a little
bit but the whole thing and I'm a little
nervous about it I want it to be over
quickly yeah I'll see you there mwah no
no sorry I didn't long yesterday I
forgot because I'm stupid
yes today is the catacomb challenge I'm
sorry you feel nervous because we
watched a movie yesterday and it was
Cask it was scary and I kept thinking
myself in those situations and I I don't
know I don't know I hope it's
I hope it's not too bad I don't know
there's like 30 people working on it and
they've been rehearsing all day
yesterday and I don't know it's like
Paul Sullivan stuff and you bros know I
can't do puzzles and it's like 40
minutes to it's like I can't even talk
420 time to go to the catacombs my
sister already I'm bringing her sweater
because apparently it's cold it's
raining outside today as well there's
someone said if it rains in the
catacombs it's gonna be wet down there
I'm wearing white skin pants nice
thinking with a packing paper I'm really
nervous and I just hope it's not too
dark down there it's gonna be cool I'm
just really nervous and I just want it
to be done we're going to Disneyland
afterwards now the only thing in my
brain is gonna be like Disneyland just
go through this and then we'll go to
Disneyland parents go through this and
they're what got it there's Mia Knight
I'll see if I survived how are you
killing
hey this is how it looks like walking
down the catacombs with the lights on I
don't want to show anything more because
you're gonna see everything in the
challenge video that's coming up it's
going to be awesome you bros are gonna
love it oh my god I'm so glad it's over
for Disneyland we have a VIP tour guys
so we get to pass all the lines it's
gonna be awesome we get to pass all the
people
that was like the craziest ride ever I
was literally crying it was so agreat my
belly's still like good I thought it
would be shield because he's Disney but
now it's not
this is goodbye to Disney it's been a
great day
a great life that's so tacky wanna go
home we don't we're leaving today we did
some shooting for the catacombs as well
today the catacombs channel which was
really cool really scary it's gonna be
an awesome video you boys are gonna love
it and today we're just going to check
out some great stuff and sit before we
leave and why don't you come along and
it's raining I said it twice you're
buying she forgot it right yeah you had
a bag women and their handbags that look
good people are watching me so it's
raining it's a really shitty day to be
embarrassed to be honest because rain
everything is closed I'm kind of glad
we're going back home today I missed the
dogs and there's look at her stupid that
was kidding she's beautiful that's for
you
now at my tap that's gonna go journey I
have a lot of fun
I think I'm gonna I'm pretty tired of
traveling I think I got a teleport okay
I'm going to pick up bugs that we just
came back and there's people walking
probably wondering what I'm doing yeah
I'm excited to see the dog here emember
me she never a manga she look at her my
ass yes and I get oh my god let's not
forget about it oh here you go oh this
is gonna be a fight alright this is
worse I might drive with the dogs I'm
gonna have to tie him down oh yeah all
right I'll see you said guys like I
don't want to lose this core I don't
want to go again come on come on come
again come on ah so we're finally back
home it was a great trip I had a lot of
fun the day we did the catacombs
challenge and Disney was one of my
favorite days in a long time so it's
really awesome and if it weren't for you
bros I wouldn't even be able to go on
awesome trips and do cool projects like
this so thank you so much for all your
support Bros it really means so much to
me
you're the best final kit bro kiss there
we go
you'll write it for the yesh
I'm kidding let's do breakfast enough
for kissing for one video all right
thanks so much for us stay awesome